en lo que respecta a los osciladores
armónicos simples las masas en los
resortes son el ejemplo más común pero
el siguiente ejemplo más común es el
péndulo y es lo que vamos a hablar en
este vídeo un péndulo es una masa m
conectada a una cuerda que tiene una
longitud l de manera que podemos hacer
hacia atrás cierto espacio y después
dejar que se columpia una y otra vez va
a columpiarse hacia adelante y luego
hacia atrás y de nuevo adelante y hacia
atrás oscilando justo como un oscilador
armónico simple y es por eso que lo
estudiamos cuando vemos este tema de
osciladores armónicos simples y
técnicamente hablando debemos decir que
este es un péndulo simple ya que es
solamente una masa conectada a una
cuerda lo cual no es complicado podemos
tener ejemplos más complejos si por
ejemplo a esta masa le conectaremos otra
cuerda y a esa cuerda le pusiéramos otra
masa esto se vuelve bastante complicado
de hecho esto se vuelve lo que los
físicos llaman caos
lo que es bastante genial si no lo han
visto busquen el doble péndulo es
bastante genial pero bastante complicado
de describir matemáticamente así que no
vamos a molestarnos con esto ya tenemos
suficientes cosas que estudiar con el
péndulo simple podemos aprender mucho
sobre el movimiento simplemente
analizando este caso y a qué nos
referimos con que el péndulo es un
oscilador armónico simple pues significa
que va a tener una fuerza restauradora
proporcional al desplazamiento lo que
significa que se puede describir con la
ecuación del oscilador armónico simple
si recuerdan esa ecuación luce así una
variable x que es función del tiempo que
es igual a cierta amplitud multiplicada
por el seno o el coseno aquí vamos a
escribir coseno de 2 dividido entre el
periodo multiplicado por el tiempo y si
ustedes quieren podemos agregar una
constante de fase pero en este caso no
la vamos a usar porque no la necesitamos
es la ecuación del oscilador armónico
simple como aplicamos esta ecuación para
el caso del péndulo bueno aquí no voy a
usar x la variable más común de usar
aquí una variable para describir a un
péndulo es el ángulo en el que se
encuentra el péndulo así que consideren
que esta masa va a tener diferentes
ángulos en diferentes instantes del
tiempo así que comienza a khan digamos
que está a 30 grados y comienza a
balancearse a los 20 luego a los 10
luego llega a 0 porque estamos midiendo
los ángulos a partir de este eje
vertical y luego continúa balanceándose
digamos a menos 10 después a menos 20
llega a menos 30 y todo el proceso se
repite de nuevo por lo que en lugar de
usar x vamos a usar theta vamos a tener
un ángulo como función del tiempo así
que teta como función del tiempo va a
ser igual a cierta amplitud pero
nuevamente ya que estoy midiendo a theta
mi amplitud no va
a una distancia o desplazamiento en x
este no va a hacer el desplazamiento
máximo regular sino que va a ser el
máximo desplazamiento angular a partir
de la posición de equilibrio esta línea
de aquí es nuestra posición de
equilibrio ya que si ponemos la masa
aquí y la dejamos reposar continuará
reposando no habrá una fuerza neta aquí
es sólo cuando desplazamos la masa lejos
de su punto de equilibrio es que
tendremos una fuerza restauradora así
que aquí tendremos y le voy a llamar
theta máxima ya que este es el máximo
desplazamiento angular que tenemos
cuando jalamos esta masa el mayor ángulo
que vamos a tener al desplazar la
cualquiera que éste sea quizás son 20
grados quizás son 30 grados ese será el
ángulo que yo ponga aquí y luego lo
multiplicamos por el coche no íbamos a
tener el mismo argumento aquí 2 pi entre
el periodo por t
recordemos que el periodo es el tiempo
que le lleva a este péndulo reiniciarse
o completar todo un ciclo
no debemos de multiplicar por t
minúscula que es nuestro tiempo es
nuestra variable y es justo lo que hace
que esto sea una función del tiempo y
aquí debo hacer una aclaración
técnicamente hablando el péndulo simple
no es un oscilador armónico simple
perfecto es muy cercano hacer un
oscilador armónico simple perfecto y de
hecho para ángulos pequeños esto solo
estaría alejado menos de un 1% y es por
eso que muchas veces tratamos al péndulo
simple como un oscilador armónico simple
pero técnicamente hablando esto
solamente funciona muy bien cuando
tenemos ángulos pequeños si nuestro
ángulo es menor a 20 grados conforme
llegamos a amplitudes más grandes esto
se va a desviar cada vez más aunque
quizá todavía sea razonablemente cercano
digamos que un 20% pero solo con ángulos
pequeños es que esto es extremadamente
cercano así que si tenemos un péndulo
que tiene un ángulo máximo de 20 grados
o menos
entonces podremos considerarlo como un
oscilador armónico simple y esta
ecuación lo va a describir bastante bien
así que vamos a suponer que estamos en
ese rango de ángulos pequeños si tenemos
esto una de las preguntas que nos
podemos hacer es cuál es el periodo que
va a tener este péndulo y de qué depende
que podríamos cambiar que afecte al
periodo aquí de que depende el periodo
bueno mi primera idea es que quizá
depende de la masa pensemos en ello
si yo incremento la masa incrementaremos
el periodo del péndulo o lo disminuirá o
lo dejará igual algunas personas podrían
pensar que si se aumenta la masa vamos a
aumentar la inercia de esta masa o del
sistema y va a ser más difícil de mover
cuando algo tiene mucha inercia se mueve
con mucha más lentitud es más difícil de
mover y de cambiar su dirección lo que
significa que debería llevarle más
tiempo completar un ciclo quizá eso
significa que el periodo debería
aumentar
ya que el tiempo aumentaría pero otras
personas podrían decir a ver un momento
si aumentamos la masa esto va a aumentar
la fuerza gravitacional la gravedad va a
estar jalando hacia abajo con mayor
fuerza y en este caso la gravedad va a
ser la fuerza que va a estar restaurando
esta masa de vuelta a su posición de
equilibrio la gravedad va a estar
jalando hacia abajo y si jalamos hacia
abajo con una mayor fuerza podríamos
pensar que esta masa se va a columpiar
con una mayor rapidez y si tiene mayor
rapidez pues va a completar este ciclo
en menos tiempo ya que se está moviendo
más rápido por lo que podemos pensar que
el periodo va a disminuir
estos dos efectos se cancelan
exactamente el hecho de que la masa
tenga mayor inercia cuando aumentamos la
masa pues va a ser más difícil de mover
y además la fuerza se va a incrementar
debido a que va a aumentar la fuerza de
gravedad y ambas se van a compensar
exactamente por lo que esta masa no va a
afectar al periodo así que resulta algo
extraño el que cambiemos la masa aquí no
nos va a afectar el periodo del péndulo
imagínense que ustedes van a un parque y
se suben a un columpio se columpian
adelante y atrás y luego llega un niño
de 5 años y se columpia también el
periodo del movimiento de este niño que
se está corrompiendo va a ser el mismo
que el periodo que nosotros tenemos al
columpiar nos ya que la más aquí al
final no afecta al periodo así que es
algo extraño pero es cierto y hay que
tenerlo en mente la masa no afecta al
periodo así que qué es lo que afecta al
periodo voy a escribir aquí abajo la
fórmula
no la vamos a deducir ya que la
deducción requiere del uso de cálculo y
es una deducción sorprendente si ustedes
ya saben cálculo deberían revisarla pero
en caso de que no hayan visto cálculo
pues vamos a escribir la fórmula tal
cual aquí vamos a analizar de qué trata
esta fórmula y quizás con esto ustedes
tengan algo de intuición del por qué
esta fórmula tiene las variables que
tiene la primera variable es l arriba
tenemos la longitud de la cuerda y la
aceleración debida a la gravedad la g
minúscula va aquí abajo y por qué es así
esta fórmula
bueno este 2 pi es una constante tenemos
la raíz cuadrada y aquí arriba tenemos a
él por lo que incrementar la longitud
nos va a incrementar el período
qué es así piensen en esto una masa en
una cuerda rotando adelante y atrás si
hay rotación una cantidad que es útil
pensar es el momento de inercia el
momento de inercia de esta masa en esta
cuerda va a ser igual a esta masa
puntual rotando sobre un eje el eje de
rotación es este punto de acá y una masa
puntual rotando sobre un eje está dada
por m por r al cuadrado
este será el momento de inercia pero
esta r es la distancia del eje a la masa
por lo que esto es m por l al cuadrado
este es el momento de inercia y vean que
si incrementamos la longitud de la
cuerda aumentaremos el momento de
inercia y si una longitud mayor nos da
un momento de inercia mayor qué
significa esto el momento de inercia es
una medida de qué tan difícil es darle
una aceleración angular a algo
es una medida de qué tan lenta va a ser
esta masa cuando la querramos mover para
que tenga algún cambio en su velocidad
angular así que un mayor momento de
inercia significa que va a ser más
difícil tomar esta masa y balancear la
adelante y atrás y cambiar su dirección
y ya que es más difícil de mover esta
masa le llevará más tiempo completar un
ciclo y es por eso que una mayor
longitud significa un mayor momento de
inercia y un mayor momento de inercia
significa que nos lleva más tiempo mover
la masa lo que finalmente nos va a
incrementar el periodo y quizá algunas
personas no acepten esto si son
espabilados me pueden decir a ver un
momento si esta longitud aumenta aquello
que causa que esto se acelere angular
mente es el torque y yo conozco la
fórmula del torque esta fórmula luce así
el torque es igual a r por efe por el
seno de teta
es la distancia desde el eje hasta donde
se aplica la fuerza y cómo es la
gravedad lo que proporciona el torque
esa r también va a ser esta l pues vamos
desde el eje hacia el punto donde se
está aplicando la gravedad así que aquí
tengo l por la fuerza de gravedad por el
seno de teta y me pueden decir mira si
la l aumenta también va a aumentar la
cantidad de torque así que tengo más
torque que va a estar moviendo esta cosa
de aquí para allá y también tengo más
inercia lo que hace que esto sea más
difícil de mover estas características
se compensan entre sí como muchas de
estas otras cosas que vimos que se
equilibran perfectamente pues no fíjense
en este torque éste va a aumentar cuando
aumente l pero solo va a aumentar
directamente lo que aumente l es
directamente proporcional a l en cambio
este momento de inercia es proporcional
a l al cuadrado así que si duplicamos la
longitud vamos
a cuadruplicar lo difícil que es de
mover esta masa pero solo habremos
duplicado la habilidad de este torque de
mover esta masa lo que significa que le
va a llevar más tiempo completar el
ciclo por lo que el periodo va a
aumentar este torque más grande no va a
compensar el que esta masa sea más
difícil de mover por el incremento de
inercia de esta masa así que la longitud
aumenta el periodo pero el incrementar a
lage la aceleración gravitacional
disminuye el periodo piensen en esto si
yo aumento la aceleración gravitacional
no se tomó este péndulo y lo llevo a un
planeta que sea mucho más grande o
masivo que va a jalar hacia abajo con
una mayor fuerza de gravedad una mayor
que quiere decir una mayor fuerza de
gravedad jalando hacia abajo esta masa
lo que me dará una mayor fuerza
restauradora y una mayor fuerza quiere
decir que me va a jalar a esta masa
mucho más rápidamente tendrá una mayor
aceleración lo que hará que tenga una
mayor rapidez de manera que se va a
columpiar más rápido
y si se mueve más rápido le llevará
menos tiempo a completar un ciclo y es
por eso que el aumentar la aceleración
gravitacional me va a disminuir el
periodo me va a aumentar la fuerza y me
va a decrementar el periodo
esencialmente si ustedes saben de torque
vamos a aumentar la fuerza que aumenta
el torque lo que me va a aumentar la
aceleración angular y le llevará menos
tiempo a esto ir adelante y atrás por
eso disminuye el periodo si aumentamos
la aceleración gravitacional y si son
aún más avispados me pueden decir eso es
casi igual a la fórmula de una masa en
un resorte tomamos el periodo de una
masa en el resorte que es de dos tipos
raíz cuadrada de algo entre algo y el
término en el numerador de la masa en un
resorte es la masa conectada al resorte
y el término de abajo era la constante
del resorte así que me pueden decir a
ver
esta es la misma idea el aumentar la
masa significa aumentar la inercia de
ese sistema y es por eso que le lleva
más tiempo completar un ciclo completo
lo mismo aquí el aumentar la longitud
significa incrementar la inercia al
menos la inercia rotacional de este
sistema por lo que le va a llevar más
tiempo completar un ciclo y me pueden
decir que aumentar el valor de k es
incrementar la fuerza restauradora en el
sistema al aumentar la fuerza en el
sistema vamos a aumentar la aceleración
ocasionando una mayor rapidez lo que
hace que le lleve menos tiempo completar
un ciclo y es por eso que esta constante
cada del resorte me va a disminuir el
periodo si aumenta lo mismo con esta g
el aumentar la que va a aumentar la
fuerza lo que va a hacer que el sistema
tenga una mayor aceleración ocasionando
mayor rapidez y haciendo que este
periodo se realice en menor tiempo así
que estas fórmulas son muy parecidas y
completamente análogas tenemos
un término de inercia arriba un término
de fuerza abajo y ambos afectan al
periodo de la misma manera una cosa más
que debemos notar es que la amplitud no
afecta al periodo de una masa en un
resorte y la amplitud o esta theta
máxima tampoco afectará al periodo de un
péndulo siempre y cuando el ángulo de mi
amplitud sea pequeño por lo que debemos
suponer que nos encontramos en esta
región de la pequeña amplitud en donde
está más en una cuerda se comporta como
un oscilador armónico simple y si esto
se cumple para ángulos pequeños la
amplitud no va a afectar al periodo en
el péndulo de la misma forma que la
amplitud no afecta al periodo de una
masa en un resorte veamos una última
cosa aquí este péndulo simple solamente
se va a comportar como un oscilador
armónico simple para ángulos pequeños lo
que significa que esta fórmula del
período para el péndulo solo se cumple
para ángulos pequeños pero
qué tan pequeño tiene que ser este
ángulo para darnos una idea digamos que
está theta máxima o la amplitud de qué
tan lejos vamos a jalar esta masa para
que este péndulo comience a oscilar es
menor a 20 grados
si la jalamos menos de 20 grados la
cantidad que nos va a entregar esta
fórmula va a estar alejada comparada con
el verdadero valor del periodo del
péndulo va a estar alejada por menos del
1% así que esta fórmula va a estar muy
cercana al valor real del periodo del
péndulo está muy cercana a ser un
oscilador armónico simple aquí y digamos
que la teta máxima es menor a 40 grados
aún así estaremos alejados por menos del
3% del valor real así que el valor de
esta fórmula va a estar alejado del
valor real del periodo por menos del 3%
y ahora digamos que mi theta máxima es
menor a 70 grados si jalamos nuestra
masa 70 grados antes de dejarla ir l
porque va a tener esta fórmula va a ser
menor al 10% no es tan bueno pero aún es
cercano así que esta fórmula que nos da
el periodo del péndulo funciona muy bien
para ángulos pequeños conforme este
ángulo aumenta el valor que obtenemos de
esta fórmula se va a desviar del valor
real una cantidad mayor cada vez en
resumen para ángulos pequeños o es decir
amplitudes pequeñas podemos considerar
al péndulo como un oscilador armónico
simple y si la amplitud es pequeña
podemos encontrar el periodo del péndulo
usando dos por pi raíz cuadrada de l / g
donde él es la longitud de la cuerda y
que es la aceleración debida a la
gravedad en la ubicación en donde se
está columpiando el péndulo